the Hoffa River between Berlin and
Potsdam is a popular destination with
day-trippers Howard bindler's houseboat
is an eye-catcher and not just because
of its modern design it is something out
of the ordinary it provides a unique
kind of lifestyle you can really chill
out here and you always feel like you
are on vacation even if you arrive home
stressed out soon start to feel relaxed
a physiotherapist by profession harold
knows all about the need to relax
welcome to my houseboat the main house
ward
the pared down interior lends the rooms
the spacious feel and blends well with
the natural surroundings
floor-to-ceiling windows provide
excellent views of the outdoor scenery
guests can sleep on this couch the
kitchen includes a microwave dishwasher
and modern stove the houseboat has a
processing unit for drinking water as
well as its own generator it might only
be five square meters in size but the
bathroom seems spacious there's even a
small sauna the cozy feature for cold
winter days I wanted all the mod cons
you have in a flat or a normal house
didn't want to give up anything
and that is why I had my houseboat built
this way Harold's favorite spot is the
bedroom at the stern of the vessel he
can take a quick morning dip to start
the day the sofa bed is easily opened up
here and the windows can be darkened
space is used to a maximum space is of
course limited on a houseboat and that
is one of the few drawbacks Alastair I
can store some of my things in the
closet and there are other storage
facilities in the house so here I have a
great view these windows have double
glazing so it doesn't get cold in winter
the 50 square meter living area has
underfloor heating and the boat also
features a generous 60 square meter
rooftop terrace
for me customers every few plots it was
important for me to have plenty of space
to be able to dine out on the roof
terrace as well as have a lounge and a
pool ways heated pour Tom they're suing
farm but if he feels like a cool
refreshing dip who doesn't have to go
far
the houseboat was built in Dresden at a
cost of 400 thousand euros and then
shipped to Berlin but that wasn't the
only obstacle Harald had to overcome the
toughest challenge for a houseboat owner
is to find a mooring they are in short
supply in Berlin and almost impossible
to come by right now Harald has found
one but he'd much rather be anchored in
the middle of the river friends can use
the dinghy when they visit the terrace
is the perfect place for a barbecue on
warm summer evenings I really enjoy
being on board this boat whatever the
weather it's simply perfect
time to raise their glasses to the host
powered wind lers floating home is the
perfect place to get away from the
hustle and bustle of life on land in the
city